[Music]
the Bolton's are defeated the war is
over winter has come
if the maesters are right it'll be the
coldest one in a thousand years we
should ride home and wait out the coming
two dogs the war is not over and I
promise your friend the true enemy won't
wait out the storm he brings the storm
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video I had to stop the
breakdown videos for now so I could
bring you these brand new spoilers
coming from Watchers on my balls
over on the free folk subreddit before I
go any further let's just take a moment
to appreciate that username Watchers all
my balls that's definitely not shots
fired but anyhow this person uploaded
around 20 new photos that show the
aftermath of one of the biggest battles
in Game of Thrones history and yes I'm
talking about that battle the battle the
Great War I will show you some of the
pictures but the new images aren't the
most fascinating update today according
to this person there will be at least
two major deaths during this battle but
I will discuss that near the end in case
some of you don't want to hear any of
the big potential spoilers first let's
talk about this battle that's taking
place in the north most likely at
Winterfell
most of us already know they have been
filming some action sequences at the
Winterfell said they completely
refurbished the castle and fitted it
with some new defensive weapons they
filmed there for a few weeks and some
photos and videos were leaked during
that time as we all know the castle was
set on fire and there was images of
hundreds of corpses scattered across the
battlements there wasn't too many clear
images of the corpses but we have a good
idea about who will be involved we know
there will be unsolved and Dothraki plus
several different Northern armies
because this is where Jon and Daenerys
are going to set up camp when they
arrive and one of these photos you can
see some dead men from the unsullied but
then they change locations and they have
been filming the rest of the battle
where they have constructed this giant
green screen there have been several
reports coming out during this filming
and even some photos and
videos but they were all taken from a
very far distance so it was hard to see
exactly who was involved but that's
until now thanks to Watchers on my balls
this person was able to walk around this
set and take up-close photos in the
daytime as you can see in these new
photos there will be several different
Northern armies there are Karstark
Mormont and stark shields laying on the
ground and there is also men wearing the
big plate steel armor from the Vale and
there is also dead men wearing the
Greyjoy sigil which is interesting
because we all know there are two
different factions of the Greyjoy
soldiers right now Euron Greyjoy has the
majority of the Ironborn men but Theon
has also a small team of his own your
own sigil is a little different because
his banners display the red eye on the
Kraken
but these could still be his men also
depending on when this battle happens
Theon and Yara may have overthrown Euron
by this time but I don't really want to
go into that too much in this video
because there is more interesting news
to discuss amongst all these dead bodies
there was also more men wearing the
unsullied uniforms and there are also
corpses that look like they could be
whites those are definitely some creepy
looking mannequins plus there are
skeletons here too which could be more
White's or they could have died from
dragon fire and they were burnt to a
crisp
I think it's anyone's guess at this
point but needless to say this will
probably be the biggest battle in Game
of Thrones history I think we all knew
that already
now I'm just gonna take a guess here but
I think the person who took these photos
must work on this set I don't know how
else they could have taken photos this
up close in the middle of the day I
think they waited until filming was done
and most of the cast and crew left
before they went walking around to get
these shots because obviously they
couldn't take pictures in the middle of
filming or else they would have been
caught and most likely fired and the
reason why I'm saying this is because it
leads me to what this person said next
because I found this to be very
interesting according to Watchers on my
balls there is some additional
information that they were unable to
capture in photos this person says Jaime
Lannister will die in brianne's arms
and Melisandre will fight the night king
by herself and hold her own for a time
but she will ultimately lose but it also
says during this battle Melisandre will
display the power of being able to
control the night Kings army and turn
them against him now that is crazy
obviously there is no proof of this but
since this person brought us all these
great images I think we should at least
consider what this person has to say
that doesn't mean it's true but this
definitely intrigues me so let's discuss
these two things for a few minutes first
I actually agree with the part about
Jamie dying in Brian's arms if you have
watched all my videos you would know
that I actually predicted this what
happened I have always thought Jamie
would die in this battle and he would
die in the arms of the woman that he
loves
but that woman wouldn't be so see it
would be Brienne personally I don't
think that is too crazy of a thing to
say and it would be nice if there was
some more proof of this happening but I
understand not being able to take photos
during the filming especially when this
person is able to get this close it
appears as if this person works on this
set based on how many up-close photos
they did have after filming was done for
the day I also know a report they just
come out a few days ago and it said
Jaime and Brienne was seen filming on
the set together fighting side-by-side
and it also said Jaime Lannister has a
much bigger beard this season we all
know Jaime was heading north so it's
very plausible that he would be involved
in the Great War and we also know Jaime
only has one hand and he can barely
defend himself these days he has nearly
died in every fight he has been in since
he lost his sword hand so I think when
you consider the scale of this battle I
think every main character will find
themselves what their bags pushed up
against the wall and unfortunately for
Jamie he is not a competent swordsman
that he once was so I think it is very
likely that he could fall on the
battlefield I've always thought that
Jaime would die trying to save someone
and I've always said he would die trying
to save one of the Starks are trying to
save Brienne but I don't want to spend
too much time on this until there is
further proof or at least some images of
Jaime fighting I just thought you should
know what this person is claiming
happens because this is some pretty damn
significant news
if it's true now the part about
Melisandre is fascinating because we
have never seen her display powers quite
like these I always thought if anyone
was going to be able to take over the
knight king's army it would have to be
bran stark because Brian already has
very strong warding abilities like the
knight Cain
but if Melisandre does this it
completely changes everything this could
turn into a true battle of real or
versus the great other ice versus fire
and I know Melisandre had a big part to
play still but I never expected her to
do something like this I kind of hope
this is true because I would love to see
this happen actually
Melisandre said she was leaving Westeros
but she also said she would be coming
back and she told Jon before she left
Winterfell that she could help him
defeat the night King but she never said
how she could help him I've been ready
to die for many years
if the Lord was done with me so be it
but he's not you've seen the night King
John snow you know the great war still
to come you know the army of the Dead
will be upon us soon and you know I can
help you win that war we have seen
Thoreau's and Melisandre resurrect the
dead before but we have yet to see them
control the dead unless you want to
consider John and barracks still dead
if Melisandre was able to turn the night
Kings army against him this would add a
completely new dynamic to her abilities
I'm still trying to wrap my head around
how she would be able to do this if it
would happen to be true if there was
more proof of this I would love to
speculate a little further but I don't
want to go too deep down the rabbit hole
right now let me know what you think
about these new developments obviously
the photos are real but what do you
think about what this person said about
Jamie and Melisandre do you believe it
or not let me know because I am
interested in knowing what other people
have to say about this I figured I would
just make an update video for now but if
anything else comes out about this then
I will make another video and go further
into what I believe about Melisandre's
role in the great war I want to thank
everyone for stopping by to watch this
quick update video and I also want to
thank all of my supporters on patreon
I really appreciate everyone's support
have a great day I will see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]